la parité qu'est ce que c'est
c'est prendre une femme pour ce qu'elle
est et non pas pour ce qu'elle fait
excusez moi c'est humiliant pour les
femmes et c'est humiliant pour ce que
vous défendez c'est à dire le fait que
les femmes comme vous l'avait dit et
comme je suis d'accord avec vous ont une
intelligence évidemment peuvent
évidemment prendre tous les rôles toutes
les fonctions tous les métiers donc
elles n'ont pas besoin
elles n'ont pas besoin d'avoir une
mesure de discrimination positive parce
que vous le vouliez ou non ça s'appelle
de la discrimination positive en tout
cas c'est la traduction qu'on en fait du
mécanisme inventé par les américains
donc ça veut dire que on favorise les
femmes parce qu'elles sont femmes moi je
considère que les femmes comme vous
l'avez dit on une intelligence bien et
galop à celle des hommes et donc peuvent
avoir les mêmes métiers que les hommes
et donc et donc il n'y a pas besoin
c'est loin vers chamakh mais j'ai
toujours dit sa bombe mais encore une
fois mais bien sûr mais il n'avait pas
dit ça mais il ya une différence il ya
une différence madame reno il ya une
différence c'est que moi j'estime que
une femme n'est pas un homme et qu'un
homme n'est pas une fin mais j'en suis
parfaitement consciente et ben voilà
c'est je suis une femme et je ne suis
pas vous monsieur et ben voila vous moi
je suis concierge et nous sommes
d'accord alors si vous vous demandez une
chose est ce que vous êtes féministe est
ce que je suis féminine 2009 parce que
féministe oui je me demande si vous êtes
féministe écoutez je suis vivait répondu
toulon vous avez un peu un discours
contre feignies oui je verrai
le féminisme qu'est ce que c'est
si c'est
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
je suis féministe comme les autres en
revanche si c'est l'indifférenciation
entre les hommes et les femmes je ne
suis pas féministe si c'est la phrase
célèbre de simone de beauvoir qui est à
l'origine du féminisme on n'est pas
femme on le devient je ne suis pas
féministe je pense qu'on es femmes et
qu'on le devient parce qu'on est né
femme et qu'on devient homme parce qu'on
est né sommes donc vous voyez c'est
assez simple en fait alors vous voyez je
suis très heureuse d'être venue ce soir
parce que je n'a jamais jamais lorsque
vous avez écrit le premier sexe j mais
je n'aurais cru un seul instant que vous
diriez que vous étiez féministe
aujourd'hui j'ai dit que je n'étais pas
ou alors des
communistes je pense que vous devriez
revoir ce que vous avez écrit dans le
premier sexe et vous vous rendriez
compte que les femmes ne sont pas ceux
que vous avez décrit dans ce livre et je
voudrais également vous poser une
question
vous vous dites que vous êtes contre la
parité que vous en êtes contre les
discriminations positives
est ce que vous considérez
que aujourd'hui les femmes sont traitées
comme les hommes dans notre pays oui
véritablement avec égalité les femmes
sont traitées et guy là et de manière
égalitaire mais bien sûr avec les hommes
mais bien est ce qu ont les mêmes droits
que les femmes que les hommes et vous
oui dans tous les domaines dans tous
leurs tous les domaines de la société
les femmes sont elles étaient comme les
enchères madame d'accord est-ce que vous
pensez que loi c 10 ans la rythmique est
vraiment leur métier est-ce que ce oasis
libre et vous pensez jamais les femmes
décident d'occuper les métiers les moins
reconnu les moins valorisés les moins
payés vous pensez qu'une femme décide
d'être femme de ménage de partir de chez
elle à 6 heures du matin de laisser ses
enfants de rentrer lorsque ces enfants
ne sont pas à la maison et de repartir
ensuite à 18 heures alors que ses
enfants vont rentrer à la maison est-ce
que vous pensez que les femmes
choisissent de gagner moins que les
hommes est ce que vous pensez que les
femmes choisissent d'être assassiné tous
les trois jours par des hommes est ce
que vous considérez jeu est ce que sont
les valets la chaussée mois terminée à
terminer ce que vous pensez
véritablement qu'aujourd'hui le
président de la république aurait eu à
choisir l'égalité femmes hommes comme la
grande cause du quinquennat si les
femmes étaient véritablement traité
comme des hommes dans notre pays alors
madame aurait alors il ya beaucoup de
questions il ya beau exactement je vous
remercie de leur goût de le remarquer je
sais compter
d'abord
je ne crois pas que les hommes se lèvent
plus tard que les femmes je ne crois pas
que les hommes travaillent moins que les
femmes je ne comprends pas déjà votre
première distinction la sogc ou la
deuxième oui je pense que les femmes
choisissent leur métier ou non elles
choisissent d'être infirmière oui elles
choisissent d'être institutrice oui
elles choisissent d'être médecin oui
elle choisit là vous prenez des exemples
eric c'est pas su pas de soi que par
l'elysée attendaient une femme de ménage
il ya des hommes d'éboueurs il ya des
hommes qui peuvent excuser moi il ya des
hommes qui sont aussi au bas de
l'échelle qu'est ce que c'est que cette
distinction il ya des femmes de ménage
il ya aussi des hommes de ménage yahiya
ddd des hommes qui sont au bas de
l'échelle et qui gagnent la majorité des
métiers essentiels de notre pays et nous
l'avons vu madame moreno convoi est
essentielle la majorité pour les
missions essentielles art est vraiment
dans un gouvernement dacia le ton de
distinguer entre les expliquer les noms
des anciennes salles us